[Música]
en directo Vamos hasta Guatemala porque
hay expectativa por la visita de la
presidenta de Taiwán say in way quien
antes hizo una escala en Estados Unidos
y provocó la ira de China ante los
temores de que la mandataria pudiera
reunirse con el líder de la cámara de
representantes sin embargo Washington ha
insistido a Beijing en que no hay nada
de qué preocuparse ya que no se trata de
una visita oficial para ampliar este
tema saludamos en la ciudad de antigua
nuestro corresponsal para Centroamérica
Andrés Suárez Jaramillo Andrés muy
buenas noches cuéntanos Qué dice el
gobierno de Guatemala con respecto al
propósito de la visita de la presidenta
de Taiwán a Centroamérica
Buenas noches Andrés A pocas horas de la
visita a Centroamérica de la presidenta
de Taiwán Guatemala se prepara para
recibir con honores a la mandataria
dice se mira con recelo desde Beijing
porque bajo el principio de una sola
china se impide y se rechaza que
cualquier país en el mundo sostenga
relaciones diplomáticas simultáneas con
taipei de manera que Guatemala y Belice
fungen como dos de los 13 países del
mundo que todavía le dan un
reconocimiento a Taiwán como la
República de China y cobra importancia
particular en Centroamérica dado que
recientemente se rompieron relaciones
entre Honduras y Taiwán y Honduras se
alió con la china continental esto según
se infiere por un préstamo que habría
solicitado el gobierno hondureño a
Taiwán de 2000 millones de dólares para
reestructurar su deuda pero que le fue
negado Sin embargo a la fecha Honduras
todavía le adeuda a Taiwán 600 millones
de dólares y como un gesto de apoyo de
camaradería el presidente Alejandro
yamate y le reiteró el reconocimiento a
Taiwán sobre todo por el compartimiento
de dos valores paz y soberanía motivos
por los cuales además de apoyar a Taiwán
también reconoce a Israel en el
conflicto contra los palestinos y a
Ucrania en el conflicto contra los rusos
Andrés ahora cuál es la agenda
programada de la delegación de Taiwán en
Centroamérica
bueno para este viernes 31 de marzo se
espera que el propio canciller Mario
bucaro reciba a las 2 de la tarde hora
local en el aeropuerto de la fuerza
aérea de Guatemala la delegación de
Taiwán y de allí se dirigirán
directamente al Palacio Nacional donde
la presidenta de Taiwán se reunirá a
Puerta cerrada con el presidente
Alejandro yamate y esto previamente
después de haberle rendido honores
nosotros como medios de comunicación
conoceremos lo que ellos dos habrán
conversado en la noche 7:30 hora local
que se espera en esa declaración
conjunta de los dos mandatarios que
hablen de acuerdos de cooperación y de
inversión para el sábado la delegación
taiwanesa visitará las ruinas de Tikal
que es el icono de la arquitectura
indígena maya en Centroamérica y el
domingo visitarán un hospital El de
Chimaltenango que fue construido con
recursos de Taiwán para comenzar la
próxima semana la delegación de Taiwán
irá a Belice se reunirá la presidenta
con el Primer Ministro John briceño y
allí tendrá la oportunidad de hablar
ante el parlamento para justamente decir
que Taiwán es un país que no pertenece a
la china continental y es una nación
soberana Andrés Suárez Jaramillo nuestro
corresponsales Centroamérica gracias por
ese informe nosotros vamos a estar
pendiente de Cómo se desarrolla esa
visita de la presidenta taiwanesa en
Centroamérica